I'm trying to mix up the openings
I'll play D4
let's see what we get
gotta have at least one lunge in this
stream
yeah this is my bread and butter
Knight C3 so the two main options are D6
and D5
D6 I'm usually a bit happier to see
because now we're entering a pirates
where
white can get a very quick attack
and I don't think this is
Joe Bravo London anymore
but it's of course something that can
come from Joe Bava London repertoire
but the ideas are very direct like Queen
D2 and thought castles uh Bishop H6 and
H for H5
Eric you're playing oh no way oh I'm
playing Traveler
oh what's up Traveler
oh good luck
traveler is the creator of Rosen score
we've never played before oh wow
yeah big shout out to traveler it's also
made some like other cool
just related applications
I see rated just over 2000 in chess
but probably like Grand Master Level
programmer
yeah I gotta check Travelers Rosen score
after this
so this is a position I've had many many
times before
and there's different branches for black
there's this there's this there's this
sometimes see this move
a lot of the players delay castling
which might be like uh
a more appropriate response
all right let's move here
I looked at this line like not too long
ago
I had a game against Darius where it's
entitled Tuesday
and he played something similar
I didn't handle it correctly
I think I'm supposed to play this move
and one of the issues for black
is it's not that easy to get an E5
like E5 right away runs into takes takes
and I take
eventually win the pawn
okay so A6
A6 is actually kind of clever
because one of the moves I wanted to
play was Bishop B5
and get rid of the knights
if I play Bishop H6 now then there's E5
and maybe we trade 92
all right let's go for this
yeah the ultimate goal would be to
gather Rosen trophy for this game
but what's the most likely Rosen trophy
checkmating with Pawn
oh no my queen
hopefully not a stalemate trick
B5 okay B4 might be coming
I think I'll just continue with my plan
upon H4
before I'll play Knight ce2
does look a little bit weird to move
this Knight to E2 blocking these pieces
but the plan is just to like go for the
quick attack
oh no
North Carolina Dan says my
eight-year-old daughter played Beach
Cafe opening on chess kid
what have I done
yeah don't
I always need the disclaimer there's any
small children watching don't try those
things at home
play something appropriate
follow principles
yeah Beach Cafe I think for me it was
one and done
maybe I play there twice
what was this game
this game doesn't spell anything fun
all right Pawn H5
so it is kind of an attacking race
upon storm on the key on the queen side
I'm Pawn swimming on the king side
there's not too many defensive resources
for black
okay that's a move
so now this is where calculation
will come into play
I don't think it matters what I start
with
I might as well start with this
an idea is now I've opened the H file
whatever it takes back I'll take the
bishop I'll throw in the check
and then I'm banking on E5 in the very
end
and I think the tactics will flow really
nicely for whites
the problem is the Knight is now tied
down to defending H7
like regardless of where the king moves
E5 happens
and if takes I take back and the queen
is hit
and Knight D5 would abandon H7
I am one move away from Connect Four but
yeah Pawn E5 is way more attractive than
on D5
oh what is Beach Cafe
well it's when you move the B Pawn and
then the E Pawn and then the a pawn
and you spell beat and then you go on to
spell Cafe
and then maybe later you can spell a
headache
not sure if the beach cafe headache
opening has ever been attempted
how many letters is that
five plus four plus four
plus four again that's 17 pawn moves
okay
98.
I'm getting closer
oh there's a pawn mate okay
oh no there's not a pawn mate
there's almost a pond mate
for some reason I was looking at this
this
and then this but it's not neat
like this and then Queen B8
somehow
black stays alive Maybe
but maybe not
I think I'll play this
because there's no good way to defend G6
I'm preventing the king from running
and or hiding
yeah I don't know if we'll see any
rosendrophies this game
because after it takes I'm not meeting
with Pawn
unless I can under promote with a knight
with checkmates
it's one of the more difficult trophies
to achieve
oh can we get an oh no my queen
Queen G8
I think that would count as a Rosen
trophy
a difficult position for black
the attack kind of stalled
King C8
all right
trade down a little bit
now the king found safety somehow
I'm up at night and two Pawns
so life is pretty good
play this move
I think the plan now is to play F4 G4
Bishop G2
there's got one more attacker against
the Knight
okay maybe G3
keep the pawn solid
and no mercy here
so Bishop B5 is the only way to defend
but now I have C4
and if on poisson I take with Knight
it's just too much pressure If Bishop A4
Bishop A4 B3
woohoo
okay Knight's still pinned
there is still potential for ampa song
checkmates like E5 or uh I if I put the
pawn on D5
and then somehow provoke E5
so many dreams
play this first
block the queen
by how to actually make it happen
I need to get the Knight to C6 I and
then play Bishop h no no
or how do I make it happen
it's hard to even conceptualize
okay I'll try and deliver
there's two potential amplicons maybe
even the third potential on Busan
but if I have made in one I'd probably
just go for me than one
and keep life simple
check we're getting closer though
we're getting very close
to it do it do it win Connect Four
attack my Knights
oh it's it's becoming possible
[Music]
I know I miss Bishop H3
I don't know if traveler's watching
though maybe he's not watching
oh I'm so sad
oh where's my ampa song checkmate
how do I even like provoke it
I'll give one more chance
do it do it do it play C5
I just want my Rosen trophy yes
okay
oh what a fantasy game
thanks for the game traveler yeah maybe
there were slightly more efficient ways
to win
but
yeah this is like the third or fourth
time in my life
thanks for subbing
so now if we go to
rosencescore.com big shout out to
traveler who like implemented this whole
site
uh you can now search on chess.com as
well as leechas
and now I have a nice shortcut
and we'll do last six hours
and look at this
hey I got two rows and trophies for that
because I also checkmated with a pawn
okay
and yeah when we click into it we can
see
we can see the game
what if I do lifetime
forever
uh oh
that was quick
so I've just over 1200 rows and trophies
and I'm still missing I'm not missing
two categories I've never done the two
Bishop mates
or the night cube mate
what's a Nike cube mate
oh this is a night in the night Cube
checkmate
okay still some bucket list items to
cross off anyway that was fine I'll
probably put this game on YouTube if you
made it this far
let me know in the comments
what your rows and score is and stay
tuned for hopefully more of who's in
trophies